[Musik]
und ich begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich
amira mohammed ali die ko
fraktionschefin der linken im bundestag
vorgestern wiedergewählt frau mohammed
ali der bundestag so voll wie nie aber
nur noch 39 abgeordnete sind für die
linke eingezogen also 30 weniger als in
der vergangenen legislaturperiode
was war das für ein gefühl gestern so
dazusitzen
natürlich ist das sehr guten morgen
erstmal natürlich ist das nicht endlich
einfach wenn man jetzt mit deutlich
weniger abgeordneten im bundestag
vertreten ist das ganze wahlergebnis war
für uns ja eine schwere niederlage die
wir jetzt aufarbeiten müssen aber ich
bin wirklich zuversichtlich dass wir als
fraktion das hinbekommen eine sehr gute
oppositionsarbeit zu machen und das
soziale gewissen des bundestages zu sein
ja wir sind das soziale gewissen in
deutschland eben den deutschen bundestag
das heißt ja immer wieder von ihrer
seite aber braucht es denn dafür
wirklich die linke also im bundestag
sitzen jetzt viele jusos auch die grünen
fraktion ist linker geworden viele
wähler trauen ihr offenbar denen eine
menge zu wenn es um soziale kernfragen
geht
mehr wenn ich mir das sondierungs papier
der ampel parteien jetzt anschaue dann
finde ich sehr deutlich dass es eine
starke linke und zwei uns als linke im
bundestag braucht denn von sozialer
agenda kann ich leider nicht viel
erkennen ja es soll eine eine
mindestlohn- erhöhung kommen das ist
wirklich längst überfällig 12 euro sind
da auch sehr knapp bemessen aber das ist
es dann auch schon es gibt immer noch
keine vernünftigen sagt mindestrenten
die wir dringend bräuchten wir haben
immer noch keine abkehr von dem wirklich
schlimmen hartz4 system ist wird einfach
nur umbenannt und ich sehe vor allem
auch überhaupt keinen ansatz dafür dass
wir endlich mal gerechte steuern
bekommen in deutschland die menschen mit
kleinen einkommen mittleren einkommen
entlastet und dafür im gegenzug
diejenigen die ich sag mal salopp gar
nicht mehr wissen wohin mit ihrem ganzen
geld etwas stärker in die verantwortung
nimmt das ist alles nicht erkennbar und
da finde ich es sehr klar das ist eine
starke linke braucht also sie sagen ganz
die linke wird gebraucht aber bei ihrer
hauptzielgruppe den arbeitern und
gewerkschaft dann kommt ihre partei ja
kaum noch an gerade mal fünf prozent der
arbeiter haben laut forschungsgruppe
wahlen noch die linke gewählt unter den
gewerkschaftsmitgliedern waren es 6,6
selbst die fdp hat ja in diesen beiden
gruppen mehr stimmen geholt wie erklären
sie sich das
also das ist in der tat für uns ein ganz
gravierendes problem und was jetzt
geschehen muss ist dass wir diese die
niederlage und natürlich auch die
verluste gerade in diesen wie kann man
sagen an unserem kernklientel und vor
allen dingen bei den menschen für die
wir ja politik machen dass die uns
wesentlich geringeren und wesentlich
geringerem umfang ihr vertrauen
ausgesprochen haben ist ein problem das
muss dringend analysiert werden da
müssen wir auch ich sag mal zu uns
einander ehrlich sein in der partei ich
bin auch dafür und ich meine der
parteivorstand sieht es auch so dass wir
auch den mut haben externe expertise
einzuholen analysen zu machen und das
auszuwerten woran das gelegen hat das
ist kein einfacher weg aber den müssen
wir jetzt gemeinsam gehen nach der
wahlschlappe ist er jetzt der ruf nach
einem neuanfang ziemlich laut braucht es
denn nicht den auch personell also warum
haben sie es nicht für erforderlich
gehalten platz für einen neuanfang an
der fraktionsspitze zu machen
also meine fraktion hat mich und dietmar
bartsch vorgestern mit großer mehrheit
im amt bestätigt das zeigt ja dass wir
als fraktionsvorsitzender akzeptiert
sind und dass auch die große mehrheit
der fraktion der meinung ist dass wir
diese aufgabe weiter erfüllen aber wir
können das weder anderen auch tun das
ist ja ein kontinuität statt erneuerung
und die wollen sie also wir müssen
unbedingt die wir müssen unbedingt diese
wahlniederlage aufarbeiten und uns da
auch neu aufstellen aber wenn es jetzt
ich sag mal so einfach wäre einfach die
köpfe und ausgerechnet der fraktion
jetzt auszutauschen dann wäre das ja
eine einfache übung das ist nicht der
fall ich bin der meinung und die
fraktion bestätigt dass ja dass dieter
und ich im letzten zwei jahren gemeinsam
einen guten weg gegangen sind natürlich
müssen wir uns auch selber kritisch
hinterfragen und wir werden jetzt heute
und morgen auf einer fraktionsklausur
auch über struktur und sprechen darüber
sprechen wie wir die arbeit der fraktion
des effizienter gestalten können wie wir
die arbeitskreise reformen wollen auch
wer die arbeitskreise leiten soll hier
wird es automatisch veränderungen geben
müssen und da sind wir glaube ich auf
einem guten weg aber selbstverständlich
braucht es veränderungen aber da muss
man einfach ehrlich miteinander sein und
ich sag mal dieser ruf jetzt einfach zu
sagen naja 8000 mal die fraktionsspitzen
aus das ist von der fraktion nicht
gewünscht und ich halte das auch
wirklich für viel zu kurz gedacht also
sollte gar kein personal ausgetauscht
werden
also wir haben parteigremien und wir
haben die fraktionen die fraktion hat
jetzt entschieden dass dietmar bartsch
und ich weiter vorsitzende sein sollen
und jan korte weiter parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer
in den nächsten zwei tagen werden wir
gemeinsam auf der klausur die darüber
abstimmen und beraten wer die weiteren
mitglieder des fraktionsvorstandes sind
und alles andere sind entscheidungen in
den parteigremien das heißt im
parteivorstand auf dem parteitag im
geschäftsführenden parteivorstand da
werden an die anderen personellen
entscheidungen getroffen und vor allem
der parteitag entscheidet ja
entsprechend über die zusammensetzung
von parteivorstand über die
parteivorsitzenden das ja das ist das
gremium was das entscheidet und da
müssen die entscheidung auch gefällt
werden wir sind gespannt ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch
amira mohammed ali sehr gern